what we do finally get new Stargate and
we will which Pig in subscription you're
gonna have to pay for to watch it
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so as you know if you're a regular site
tracker I am incredibly confident that
we're going to be getting a new Stargate
series I think we're going to be getting
announcements sometime in the new year
around the launch of MGM plus if you
don't know epics in the United States is
a stream and service owned by MGM Amazon
as the new owners have now decided to
Rebrand epics into MGM plus similarly
how Paramount plus Disney plus you see
where I'm going with this if you're also
a regular site tracker you'll know that
I have a couple of people through pure
look that I get to speak to in the
industry and they get to feed me bits of
information one of those people gets to
work quite closely in marketing and they
told me a few months ago that there was
actually strategy meetings regarding
Stargate and that these meetings weren't
a right start it's been decided what are
we going to do with it kind of meeting
it was a if we decide to do Stargate how
are we going to proceed and there was
lots of discussions about the best way
to announce it to maximize clicks and
maximize interest in the series
now that person has been in contact with
me again because they've been involved
with further marketing meetings but
these meetings weren't anything to do
with Stargate but they will give us an
idea of what Amazon will decide to do
with Stargate once they decide to
finally pull the trigger and make the
series that we're also desperately
waiting to see don't forget to like
subscribe and share the video with all
of your other Gator friends also you can
go to side ashtrak.com for brilliant
Stargate related merged just like this
you can even buy socks and don't forget
the Sidetrack sides Channel where I do
loads of little live videos and other
fun stuff all the links are in the
description so what other meetings about
well in this case they were actually
mostly talking about the epics TV series
Billy the Kid and how to promote that
worldwide but more generally in the
meeting was about transferring epics
into MGM plus how to best promote the
series that currently are made directly
for epics and and what TV shows are
going to be made in the future now they
did obviously focus on the Billy the Kid
series that is currently not available
in Europe we cannot watch it anywhere I
should also say that these meetings have
been held over the last six weeks or so
epics is going to be moving over and
becoming MGM Plus on January the 15th
now when that was announced a bunch of
other TV shows Etc were also announced
second series of a few big epics
projects as well as a bunch of
unscripted stuff
Billy the Kid is obviously going to be
on epics and continue to be on MGM plus
worldwide though it will eventually
appear on Prime now
the point of this meeting was to discuss
what to do with MGM plus and what the
strategy for outside of the United
States would be for TV shows like Billy
the Kid and other shows yet to be
announced like Stargate
well the plan is as I say big TV shows
that are produced directly by MGM or
epics in this case will continue to
appear on MGM Plus in the United States
outside of the United States however
they will appear on Prime now this is
quite normal for example
the expanse the first three series and
was shown on the Sci-Fi Network in the
United States the rest of the world knew
it as a Netflix TV show as far as I knew
it was a Netflix original it said
Netflix original on the show for example
Star Trek Picard the first two seasons
appeared in the UK on Amazon but over in
the United States I believe they
appeared on CBS all access
um anybody in the comments you want to
correct me on that but I'm gonna believe
that's how it worked now we have
Paramount plus I don't actually know if
it's going to go directly to Paramount
Plus or still appear on Amazon I'm not
sure a decision to be made on that but
Amazon paid for the international
distribution rights now this will work
in a similar way to that but obviously
Amazon is the parent company so MGM
products will continue to focus on MGM
Plus
however worldwide those same products
will appear on Prime
so when new Stargate goes out if they
continue to follow along this model and
according to the meeting and the people
I've spoken to that is the plan
Stargate will appear on MGM Plus in the
United States when it is brand new now
that's very good point because I should
also say that the idea will then be that
when it's not brand new it might then
appear on Prime at a later date in the
United States to join sg1 SG Atlantis
and SG Universe
in the rest of the world the
international rights will be with Amazon
so we will see it on Amazon Prime now
I've been told previously a couple of
months ago that we will be getting
Stargate on Amazon Prime worldwide in
the coming months but that might take a
little while because there are quite big
contracts with people like Sky TV here
in the United Kingdom if you are in the
United Kingdom you watch Stargate on
either now TV or Sky both of which are
owned by Sky now they have quite a good
deal with MGM that was actually signed
before the sale went through to show
Stargate however everything actually go
on sky at the moment you'll see that a
lot of the episodes have started to
disappear we don't actually have
Stargate Universe either as the contract
comes towards an end and begins to lapse
the content is being removed and very
shortly will disappear entirely
at that point worldwide we will have all
the Stargates in one place on Amazon
Prime so there we have it
here in the UK I already have Amazon
Prime so I cannot wait for that little
Stargate symbol to appear and for me to
watch the brand new series at some point
towards the end of 2023 if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and if you really want to support
the channel become a fully fledged side
Trekker and consider hitting the join
Button as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time foreign
[Music]